hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting game this time between a future
world champion Garry Kasparov and the
former world champion Tigran Petrosian
the game was played in 1981 in Moscow
and it was a Soviet team championship
there were four teams and each team
consisted of 10 players so this is one
of the more interesting games as again
it's a kind of a clash of styles and
like I said it's played in 1981 so it's
some four years before as part of takes
away the world championship title from
Anatoly Karpov and it's been already 11
years since petrosyan lost his world
championship title to Boris Spassky so I
guess you know who is in top form here I
guess Petrosyan is a bit more out of
shape and Kasparov is a bit more in
shape you know going into his prime but
it'll definitely an interesting game and
I do I do hope you enjoy it so as part
of has the white pieces and he opens
with the d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 and
c6 now we have knife to f3 this is the
antonyms of each variation as it is it's
not the usual Knight to c3 allowing
Bishop to b4 here we have beset by
Petrosyan and we have a three this is
the petrosyan variation of the Queen's
Indian defense and Kasparov really wants
to show former world champion who's boss
as he plays the Petrosyan variation
against even petrosyan himself so Bishop
to b7 Knight to c3
we have d5 see captures on d5 Knight
characters on d5 III Bishop to e7 this
is still all Petros variation of the
Queen's Indian and here we have Bishop
to b5 check here Kasparov leaves the
variation and what's the idea of the
Bishop b5 move well it does have a
certain poison to it as if you play
Knight to c6 blocking this check you
lose the game immediately after Queen to
a4 now there's the double attack on the
night after we defended with Queen to e7
to d7 now you get Knight to e5 and now
your queen is attacked the knight is
also attacked also the knight is pinned
so you have to capture the night and
after you lose the Queen you recapture
with the night and you
have two pieces for the queen but
unfortunately that's not enough this is
a winning position for white also after
Bishop to b5 check you don't want to
block with Knight to d7 and because
again you get Knight to d5
and that night is now pinned also the
thread is Bishop captures and after you
defend this with another Knight coming
to f6 now the night is defended and now
white can simply push efore and this is
this is an excellent position for white
why can white can always play Knight to
c6 there either when the dark square
bishop or Peterson will be forced to
capture with the light square bishop so
either way
casparo will win the bishop pair here so
after Bishop to b5 patrols in place c6
and we have measured back to d3 Knight
to c3 capturing be Capra's on c3 and c5
a Petrosyan immediately challenges
Kasparov Center and releases his light
square bishop so Casper of castles
petrosyan castles and Queen to c2 now
attacking the h7 pawn g6 defending and
now comes B 4 we have 9th to c6 Bishop
to h6 attacking the rook rook to e8 and
here cos power plays rook F to d1 and
it's a very interesting position can
Petrosyan capture the pawn on d4 if
Petrosyan characters seek after son
before you get C capture some before and
after Knight captures and Knight
captures you get Bishop Queen captures
on d4 and now Bishop to b5 attacking the
rook on e8 also attacking the Queen on
d4 but it's not all so simple after
Queen captures Bishop Queen captures and
Bishop captures and now Bishop captures
rook on e 8 but rook captures Bishop on
e8 and if you look at the position now
yes Kasparov is up the exchange but
Petrosyan has the bishop pair and is
also up to pawns so a bishop pair and
being up 2 points in patrols and sense I
don't know if if that's an in game
because Parra wants to play but either
way after this rook after d1 Petrosyan
doesn't go for it he plays Queen to c7
and now Queen - e - we have rookie to d8
now there is a threat of capturing and
d4 n cos power plays Queen to e3
- the
ended and here we have a move only
Petrosyan would would dare to play
against a player like Kasparov here
petrosyan plays d5 and what do you do
here well the immediate reaction to
everyone is well of course I want to
push d5 and create a passed pawn and
this is exactly what Kasparov plays
trading down in the center doesn't
really favor white as any exchanges in
the center will favor black since
White's main advantages this big pawn
Center so Kasparov pushes d5 and here
petrosyan plays Knight to a5 now why did
Petrosyan allow this such a center well
his idea is humans to push c4 and create
a very nice outpost for this night on b3
because part of the stop just by playing
see for himself but by stopping one
threat you allow you allow another now
Petrosyan plays Knight to b3 attacking
the rook and whenever he feels like it
he was simply remain over the knight to
d4 another beautiful square where it
will stay for as long as Petrosyan likes
unless Kasparov captures it but the den
petrosyan will recapture and create a
nice pass pawn of his own so rock to a2
and not immediately going for night to
d4 but first f6 we have h4 now by
Kasparov as f6 did weaken the Kings side
cuz probably immediately pushes h4 to
try and break down down the King's
defenses and here another very nice move
by Petrosyan in his own style he plays
Bishop to c8
as here you can apply the principle of
the least active active piece for
example okay your least active piece is
obviously the rockin e8 but you can't
help this piece at the moment so Bishop
to c8 as the night is on f3 Kasparov
just pushed h4 so it would be very nice
if you could play Bishop to g4 since
Kasparov doesn't have the option of
playing pawn to h3 anymore since he
already pushed it on h4
so Caspar decides to prevent this by
playing rook to be one he forces the
night unto the d4 square we have Knights
to d4 and now Knight captures he gets
rid of the night so Peterson doesn't
have Bishop g4 pinning his rook that
wasn't
we have C capture some before and Queen
to g3 now so the bishop is isn't able to
develop on g4 here we have Bishop to f8
offering a trade of Bishops because part
of the clients does he plays Bishop to
d2 and now Bishop to d6 and here yeah
you probably want to push h5 at at some
point but not now if h5 then simply g5
and there's really nothing there so
first cuz power plays rook to f1 he will
prepare f4 and then only after he is
ready will he continue pushing his pawns
Queen to g7 we have a for now
a5 not allowing a five by Casper on
himself and looked to be two now
attacking the pawn on d6 and here
Petrosyan can prevent this with Bishop
to c7 if he also wants to keep an eye on
this a five point and the f4 square but
he decides to play Bishop to c5 as
casparo would play f4 regardless of if
Petrosyan retreated with the Bishop on
c5 or c7 so we have Bishop to c5 f4 by
Kasparov and here Bishop to d7 here
Petrosyan doesn't think that f4 really
deserves attention so instead he plays
Bishop to d7 going after a sparse
undefended pawn as part of here place h5
and this is this is quite the position
to study as what happens if G captures
on h5 why is why is part of giving up
upon if already his pawn is attacked on
a4 well let's let's see what's going on
here if G captures on h5 then Queen to
h4 the idea is rook to f3 followed by
rook to g3 as the Queen and the King are
are pretty lined up here on the G file
but Petrosyan stopped this relatively
easy with Bishop to g4 preventing the
route from coming to f3 and also
protecting his h5 pawn here F captures
on e5 f captors on e5 and now rook to f6
it's a very interesting line Bishop to
e7 and now the other rook cap
zombie six rocket or zombie 6 so here
Kasparov could give up the exchange
official captures rook captures and
after rook to f8 now simply play rook
back to b6 and now he's threatening
Bishop to h6 and it's a it's a pretty
wild attack for white let's say Bishop
to f3 now stopping Bishop to h6 with the
threat of queen g2 checkmate
so let's say Bishop to f1 defending and
rook a to b8 rook Bishop to h6 now and
after Queen to g4 rook captures rook
captures as of course you can't capture
the Queen then rook captures on a fate
would be checkmate so rook captures on
b8 and now Queen to f6 and this is a
very delicate position something that
could happen if Kasparov if patrols and
decided to play this G captures on h5 as
now you can never really do anything
with this rook rugby to rugby 1 because
you're getting checkmated Queen - FA -
checkmate the rook can't really help out
here you can't move the Queen from the G
file because Queen to g7 will be
checkmate and as part of does have these
very nice passed pawns
so if anything Kasparov definitely is
better here and even if Petrosyan could
draw this game or or do something with
it
it would be due to his extreme defensive
capabilities but it's definitely very
passive position to play for petroleum
and since Petrosyan didn't go for this
obviously he didn't like what he saw
so after this h5 move Petrosyan doesn't
capture rather he plays Bishop captures
an a4 he grabs a pawn and why not cuz
power pushes h6 and of course you can't
capture if you kept trying h6 then you
get F captures on e5 now there's a
discovery on the Queen on h6 and after
Queen to h5 now you simply capture on f6
Bishop to e 8 stopping f7 but now comes
a 5 and if you look at this monster
Center this is completely resign about a
6 is coming f7 is coming this would be
terrible so after h6
Petrosyan goes for Queen to c7
keeping an eye on that a five square we
have F 5 by Kasparov and here it's not
easy to decide what to do
Petrosyan did grab up on an a4 and now
he has to really really figure out what
to do here he played g5 and as part of
captured the pawn he sacrificed a piece
here we have F capture son g5 and now
Queen captures on g5 here Petrosyan went
came to f8 if you play King to h8 this
loses if King to h8 then comes Queen to
f6 check you can block with the Queen
because of the pawn on h6 King do it and
now rock to f3 now the rook is coming to
g3 Queen f7 rook g3 check King to f8 now
comes Queen h8 check King e7 now you
capture with the check Queen captures an
e5 check King goes back and now rook
captures on b6 it's a very important
move deflecting the bishop from the d6
square and also you're threatening rope
to f6 to window Queen so Bishop captures
and now d6 now there's the threat of
Queen to h8 because now the decent d7
square is no longer available for the
king so black could have to capture here
and after Queen captures with check and
now it doesn't really matter what you
play if you play
Queenie 7 then Ruby g8 wins the Queen
and if you play something like King to
ei eight then you get Queen capture some
b6 and and this is all over as why a
white is much better here rooks coming
to g7 there's nothing to do here for
black
so after this Queen to g5 after as part
of sacrificed a piece Petros and played
the correct King to f8 and he started
his King March we have Queen to f6 check
King to e8 and here we have looked to
a-1
you don't really gain anything by
delivering any more checks if you played
Queen to h8 then King simply escapes
King b7 King c8 and if you play Queen to
e6 then simply Queen to e8 defense
everything so Kasparov tried rook to a1
and rook to e1 is an extremely poisonous
move as the bishop is attacked you can't
really defend it if you try to defend it
these squares are protected by the pawns
if you play something like Bishop to d7
then you get Queen - h8 check after the
bishop blocks you capture on h7 and
after Queen tries to tries to help out
the black king now you get f6 and it's
this is pretty terrible the Queen
captures rook to f1 and the Queen can't
really move as Queen to f7 will be
checkmate
so after this rook to a one move
Petrosyan doesn't care about this bishop
he plays Queen to e7 and what's the idea
here why is he offering a trade of
Queens
well if Queen captures on e7 and King
captures on e7 and of course rook
captures an a4 winning back the piece
then rook to d6 going for the h6 pawn g3
making room for that rook to come into
the game rook captures the material here
the material here would be equal but
it's hard to say the rooks
both yourself two rooks opposite colored
bishops are on the board but there is
this outside pawn and it's hard to say
rook is coming to g8 it it would be it
will be a tough game but for some reason
Kasparov isn't interested in this he
still wants to really win this game so
he plays Queen to e6 and he offers an
exchange on e6 so but Rosen isn't
interested in this he plays rook to d6
again he forces Kasparov to either
capture on e7 or or get out of here
quinta g8 was played we have King Queen
to f8 and now Queen to g3 we have Queen
captures on h6 and now rook captures an
a4 and this is this is this is a pretty
weird move by Kasparov as he might he
might still have some chances with Queen
to g8 check and then the Queen has to go
back and maybe he could exchange Queens
and still still try to play this game
but for some reason he played rook
captures on a4 and after Queen to c2
check Queen to c1 check he played King
to have 2 and now after Petrosyan
captured the rockin b2
as part of resigned at the game as now
he's not down a piece he is now down a
hole rook and I mean okay maybe maybe
the King could hide maybe the Queen
could still pose some threats but he saw
that after this check and after came to
g1 after Queen to c1 check if you go to
the H file then you get rook to h6 and
it's all over and if you play King to
have to now you get King to f7 and now
there are two terrible threats here
Petrosyan has and that's Queen to d2
checked followed by Queen to d1 check
picking up the other rook and the other
threat is of course rook the g8 so if
you play a rock to a two you get a rock
out of the way you get rook the g8
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves rook rook to h6 and white is
without a move I mean it's not like
white needs a move white is down a rook
but there are no tricks or anything as
part of can try here even even the the
obvious rook to c2 false Queen captures
on c2 Bishop captures now d3 this comes
with check King moves Bishop before
check King has to go if King goes to d1
then simply rook to H 1 will be
checkmate after the Queen blocks so you
probably have to play King to f1 or or
you could go King to have to let's say
King F to D captures on c2 and after
Queen to e3 which is the only square
from where you can prevent patrols and
from promoting his pawn to Queen you get
Bishop to c5 this one's the queen and
there is nothing more for curse power as
part of here to do so
a brilliant attacking game bye-bye
future world champion garry kasparov but
an even better defending game by former
world champion Tigran Petrosian there is
this one moment in the game it was moved
35 and here it was after this King to a
fate move were Kasparov played Queen to
f6 check later Kasparov said that if he
played f6 that he would win the game
because after Queen to f7
Queen captures on e5 and after Bishop to
d6
Queen to g5
and the Troezen offering a trade of
queens now Queen to g7 check is coming
Queen captures pawn captures and after
King to g8 now rope to e2 threatening a
five and then e 6 and f7 and after this
is blocked with Bishop e5 now rook to f5
and here petrosyan would have to
probably give up one piece for some of
these pawns either by playing roof to d6
or by capturing on f6 as his Bishop is
threatened here but whether water
Kasparov would actually win this against
Petrosyan and his brilliant defensive
capabilities you know that that's
another that's another question so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
former world champion team and patron
versus future world champion Garry
Kasparov as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with another classic